well i'm joined now by omid scobee
co-author of
finding freedom great to see you thanks
for being with us on sky news it's an
interesting
title isn't it that you've chosen for
this book finding freedom
why is it called that well i think when
you look at what freedom really means
freedom to express yourself or speak up
on anything that you want that's
something that the sussexes weren't
always able to do within the institution
of the monarchy and
certainly where we look at where they're
at today talking about systemic racism
and gender equity in a way that we
hadn't seen them before it looks like
they have found some form of it
and you began the book uh a couple of
years ago but of course
uh the story changed dramatically didn't
it from what from when you
you began to write chapter one
yeah this really started out as the
chronicle of their first year of
marriage and their courtship and of
course those first days with archie
leading up to that tour in southern
africa
and of course as time went by we
realized a bigger story was building
behind the scenes and
increasingly sort of unhappy couple were
in front of us
and we found out why that was you know
it was within the institution of the
monarchy that they felt extremely
frustrated and
under-supported and under-defended from
some of the more vicious
tabloid attacks too some of the
anecdotes and stories in the book
are incredibly personal aren't they um i
know they've denied it but did you speak
with harry and megan
directly no we didn't speak with harry
megan directly
they didn't cooperate with the book and
there's certainly no secret off the
record conversations that have taken
place either
but i think the unique situation that we
had here were many of the people in
harry and megan's lives felt
increasingly frustrated
with some of the coverage that they saw
on the people that they knew that looked
so
different on the pages of some sections
of the british tabloids and
i think there was this real desire to
speak out and defense of the couple
especially when the palace wasn't doing
so themselves
uh because you know as well as i do when
journalists talk about close friends
uh uh uh and then make statements what
they actually mean is that the people
themselves
no and i understand that there's this
sort of desire to
make this the next andrew morton book
and unfortunately there is no
uh secret delivery of audio cassette
recordings from harry and megan or
private diaries or anything like that
we really have spoken to the people
close to them who are their friends who
are the people that have worked for them
past and present
those include many palace aides as well
themselves and
to also get balance we spoke with those
close to the cambridges the prince of
wales the queen herself
and so that really gave a balanced
overview of exactly what went wrong
yeah i suppose that that has been one of
the criticisms of the book
that that it's quite one-sided coming
from from from
very much from the couple's point of
view and not all the reviews have been
kind i'm sure you'll be aware of this
one today the only winners from this
oily guff of the authors cashing in
that was uh richard k in the daily mail
what did you make of that
i mean it's interesting words from a
journalist who's cashed in on their
relationship with the princess
princess diana but um i mean listen
everyone's entitled to an opinion
on this book and i think one thing that
we had really heard about harry and
megan time and time again
was the other side of the story from
within the palace we knew what other
royal family members thought of them
we knew what aids were briefing certain
sections of the press
anonymously and i think that this was a
chance just to add to that landscape
a different perspective so at least when
we look at it all we now have a much
more balanced overview of the situation
yeah and for a couple that have clearly
craved their
privacy they've wanted to keep their
private life their personal life private
i mean this book is anything but
yeah i think that there are obviously a
lot of details in here about the couple
and i really wanted to re-humanize them
in a way because it felt like for a long
time that we had
sort of lost a sense of who they were
they'd become caricatures
in certain sections of the press and i
think that this does
bring a human quality to the couple
again you know we have to remember
they are a couple that understand the
intense interest
in their lives both publicly and
privately you know only today we saw
them
confirm to a number of news
organizations that they had bought a
home in santa barbara so
they are willing to share certain
details about their lives i think
they're also not afraid to call on the
law when they see those lines crossed
yeah when it comes to
you can see you can sort of see how
people in the uk will be
raising their eyebrows if you like that
for a couple who have
said for so long they want privacy they
want to be out of the limelight
for them to then move to los angeles
which is the center of celebrity the
center of the paparazzi
is slightly strange well santa barbara
is actually a hundred miles from los
angeles so they're not in los angeles or
parts of hollywood
they're in california showbiz place
isn't it
california is one of the largest states
in america so it's hard to really call
let's show this place it is where
megan's mother lives and i think for
them as a family
picking a place where really they were
able to lay their roots and have that
support system around them was very
important
and of course when we look at america it
has a huge charitable landscape and of
course
their archwell organization which
they'll be launching
later in the year is one of the big
driving factors in the work that they're
doing
yeah um the book says megan says i gave
up my entire life for this family
it was her choice to join the royal
family though
wasn't it um she did go in with her eyes
open
absolutely and i think that there's also
a difference between knowing
what you have up ahead of you and
actually experiencing it for yourself
and
you know listen if there's one thing
that we've seen about megan she really
does give it her all she's not a quitter
and i think that
it has been this big common
misconception that
she was the one in the driver's seat for
this decision to step away and i think
in reality when we really look at the
information and
everything that we already know about
harry this was a world in which i think
he wanted to step away from anyway and
megan was someone that simply gave him
the support and confidence within that
but
i would also argue that if he had said
let's stick it out a few more years i
would imagine she would have done that
too
and just very briefly um omid how will
the story end you think
will they return to the uk one day uh
will harry want to
come back into the royal family at some
stage
i mean the queen's made it very clear to
harry and megan that the door is always
open for them to come back they're
obviously
currently in a 12-month probation period
that will be discussed
next easter to see whether it is that
they would want to come back i think
when we look at them now though they
seem very forward focused they're laying
their roots in the us
and i think the uk will play a big role
in their lives when it comes to their
patronages and of course
the family they have over here but not
as working members of it
okay i mean scobee co-author of finding
freedom we must leave it there thank you
very much